good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
and i am proud to welcome you to this
edition of our 2021 2022 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
the lecture series is supported by uva's
integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain
institute the college of arts and
sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the national
institutes of general medical sciences
this year's theme is ethical challenges
of artificial intelligence and
biomedicine where we enjoy presentations
on friday afternoons from leading
thinkers about the promise opportunities
and hurdles associated with ai
applications in the biomedical sciences
selected participants in our biomedical
data science innovation lab program have
will leverage these presentations as
vital material for our culminating
in-person grant project development
workshop to be held here in historic
charlottesville virginia in june
today i'm delighted to welcome our
speaker dr edward dove from the
university of edinburgh in scotland
ted dove is a lecturer in health law and
regulation
at the school of law at the university
of edinburgh and deputy director
of the j kenyon mason institute for
medicine life sciences and law he holds
a bachelor's degree in political science
and civil law and common law from mcgill
university a masters of law degree from
columbia university and a phd in law
from the university of edinburgh his
primary research interests are in the
areas of regulation of biomedical
research research ethics oversight
health related data access and sharing
health data protection and governance of
international research collaborations
his current research focus lies in
health data protection regulation
and research ethics committee for the
national health service in great britain
he is an editorial board member of the
asian bioethics review and formerly an
editor-in-chief of scripted an online
peer-reviewed open access journal
dedicated to law medicine society and
technology he is a co-chair of the
regulatory and ethics work stream of the
global alliance for genomic and health
and also a member of the scientific
program committee for the european
society of health genetics and a member
of the edinburgh law school's research
ethics and integrity committee he's
published works in such periodicals as
science the lancet the british medical
journal european journal of human
genetics and several others
in ted's spare time he is also the
author of the open access monograph
regulatory stewardship of health
research navigating participant
protection and research promotion and
co-author of uh
several other
legal
uh treatises on
on the use of
medical technologies and the legal
implications thereof in continuing our
2021 2022 biomedical data science
seminar series ted's lecture today is
entitled challenges for research ethics
governance in the era of ai and data
science research in ted's lecture he
will explore contemporary issues in
research ethics governing looking in
particular at ethics committees within
institutions such as universities and
the challenges these committees face
when assessing ethical issues associated
with ai and data science research he
will argue that while ethics committees
are far from perfect
in terms of regulatory design and
performance they do perform at least in
principle a valuable role in helping
steward research projects towards an
ethical endpoint and while some
modifications to their design and
performance might be warranted on the
whole they perform a very valuable
service as always we are streaming this
lecture live and for recording via
youtube if you are watching on youtube
thank you so much for joining us once
again also our specially selected
2021-22 biomedical data science
innovation lab participants are
encouraged to submit any questions they
have for ted via the chat feature in
their zoom sessions i will synthesize
these questions and ask them on your
behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of the lecture and with that welcome ted
we've really been looking forward to
your lecture
thank you very much jack and thank you
gina and thank you everyone from the
university of virginia for this
wonderful invitation an opportunity to
speak with you all today
thank you as well for that and
warm
long biography that's um overwhelming
and it makes me think do i have any free
time in fact
to do anything but i suppose i do and
the weekend is is nice so hopefully you
all have uh nice plans in store for this
early early spring time and hopefully
the weather is very nice wherever you
are and indeed good morning good
afternoon and perhaps good evening to
whoever you are in the world and
as jack said i want to speak with you
all for the next 45 minutes or so
um
about ai and data science research which
you are all way more expert in than
myself
but i want to situate
that domain or those domains within
research ethics governance and with a
particular focus on
the work of ethics committees which are
known of course in the us as irbs
research ethics boards are ebs in canada
and where i am in the uk research ethics
committees and in particular i want to
make the case that i think that data
intensive science ai
type research
is raising
new and particularly difficult
challenges for research ethics
governance and in particular that the
work that ethics committees do
and i think it's worthwhile to spend
some time focusing on what those
challenges are external or internally
imposed
and whether it means that we need to
rethink the nature of research ethics
governance and in particular how these
committees are constituted and in other
words
is reform needed and if so how radical
must the reform be so hopefully we can
have a nice discussion about that
so in terms of what i want to do then
over the next
little while is go through four main
areas
i think it's worthwhile to start looking
at the nature of ethics communities so
both are form and their function and i
must say that this presentation will try
to have a relatively high level view not
necessarily taking a specific
jurisdictional focus
and i'm not situated in the us of course
so my knowledge of irbs and the common
rule and hipaa and related
regulatory instruments is limited
i'm more knowledgeable of uk
frameworks and so i will make more
reference to the uk but i am going to to
endeavor to try to keep this as high
level as possible so that it will have
resonance with with wherever you are
situated in the world
i'll then briefly talk about some some
themes as i see it from ai data science
in big data and how in particular those
themes can throw up particular
challenges for research ethics
governance and the work that ethics
committees do
as part of that we'll look at the
changing role of ethics committees in
research ethics governance and how
there's been a confluence both of
long-standing criticisms and challenges
that these ethics committees face as
well as novel ones as they say that are
raised by ai data science and big data
whether together that means are ethics
committees still fit for purpose can
they do their work well or are the
criticisms and challenges so valid that
we need to actually think about reform
and as i say how radical reform is
necessary
and so ultimately that that is where i
hope we can go and and we'll have as i
say time for plenty of discussion uh
about this and whether we think that
research that's governance and the work
work of ethics committee remain fit for
purpose
in the 21st century
so let's start by looking at the nature
of ethics committees
i think it's worth first making an
argument i i won't have time to unpack
this argument but i think it's worth us
starting with with a viewpoint that the
work of ethics committees
is a form of regulation
and law and regulation are both very
notoriously tricky concepts to define
not least just because of cultural
variation and ascribing meaning to
phenomena that we might say is legal or
regulatory so there isn't there's
necessarily going to be varying
definitions depending on one's
viewpoints epistemology culture and so
on
we might define law at least in its
positivistic sense
as a system of rules codes
pronouncements
promulgated by state or state like
actors within a particular community so
it could be national sub-national
international
with the aim of regulating the actions
of its members
and which it may enforce by
the imposition of penalties so we can
think of judgments from a court of law
we can think of course of acts of a
parliament or of congress
state like or state actors that write
rules
make pronouncements judicial
pronouncements or otherwise and that
have the backing of of the state in
other words imposition of law penalty
sanction and so on
we can contrast that with regulation
which i think is a broader category and
include can include much more flexible
and innovative forms of social control
so and
this definition i i took from from the
book that jack referenced regulatory
stewardship of health research i think
regulation
to be more broadly defined as i say so
we could say it's perhaps a set of rules
principles mechanisms strategies or
activities
that can be promulgated both by state
actors but as well as non-state actors
that ultimately seek to affect behavior
either as an incidental effect of
probably more desirably to steer
behavior in some socially politically or
economically desirable way
so in this definition the state is not
necessarily privileged it's simply one
node amongst many actors that can share
control of resources
what that means then
is that we might see that various sorts
of of actors or bodies including irbs
and ethics committees as regulators they
are seeking to steer researchers in a
socially and obviously ethically
desirable manner so their work is a form
i would argue of social control of
science and indeed a form of regulation
i think it's really important to
emphasize that point
why
because when we turn to start to look at
how research and i define research very
broadly applying some sort of
scientifically sound method to derive
generalizable knowledge not necessarily
just health research or other forms of
research we can think of research
so in so many different ways
but generally research involving humans
of course directly or indirectly but
brings us into the realm of research
ethics governance
as well as as we'll talk about shortly
uh uh
data involving humans so again we could
think of human involvement in broad and
broadening sense
but research itself is regulated through
a patchwork of instruments of regulatory
control
we can think at the highest level of
ethical frameworks so
thinking with our biomedical hats on we
might think about the declaration of
helsinki which of course has been in
existence since the 1960s before that in
the nuremberg code from 1948-49
the scions guidelines medical sciences
based in geneva they've come out with
with new guidance from 2016 but
originally from 1982.
we can think of public law so
administrative laws announcements from
courts of law criminal law
domestic and international legislation
so every country will have clinical
trials rape legislation medical devices
legislation and this is of course just
looking at the biomedical context
depending on where you are situated in
the world you might have human rights
instruments that apply to you those of
us
who are member states of the council of
europe which is currently 47 member
states perhaps one less recently um
abides by the european convention on
human rights and so we have domesticated
that in the uk through the human rights
act 1998 but many countries will have
human rights legislation that applied to
it that might have even been
domesticated through through domestic
law so the highest level we could think
about the universal declaration human
rights
from 1948 at the united nations as well
as the international covenant on civil
and political rights from the 1960s and
some countries have adopted the economic
and social uh rights uh international
declaration from the u.n as well
we can also think about common law and
by common law i mean law that is
promulgated through judicial
pronouncement not through acts of
congress or parliament so
confidentiality law is primarily a
common law uh domain professional
secrecy and tort law contract law much
more driven by judicial pronouncement
than a statue
professionals and governmental guidance
is also a key element of research and
regulation thereof so we can think about
um certain professional bodies
researchers themselves of course are not
professionals but they might be um
uh you know
ai is increasingly becoming a sort of
professional workforce or data
scientists and there might be
professional associations that put out
codes of conduct for how those that are
seen to be professionals ought to
conduct themselves ethically in going
about their work
there might be a regulatory authority in
place so in the uk we have the health
research authority in the domain of
health research
but there are other regulatory
authorities that might be at play of
course
if you're doing a clinical trial in the
us that the fta would be most at play
but there might also be funders who have
their policies so quasi quasi regulators
so that's further down as you see the
nih of course will have its own policies
and what i'm trying to emphasize here is
ethics committees which i've highlighted
are but one known in this patchwork of
instruments of control
but they played an
incredibly important role as i'll
emphasize in a minute but i just wanted
to put this up here to really illustrate
the patchwork of instruments of control
that are at play here
ethics committees
you know we often talk and think about
them as if they've been in existence
forever
but of course research itself or the
modern form of research and science
really only came about um in the 18 i
don't know 1870s and 1880s primarily in
russia
when when when leading scientists there
started to to to conduct um and apply
scientifically sound methods to develop
generalizable knowledge not through
observation but through experimentation
and that's really only been in existence
in the
1880s and from
roughly
1880s 1870s through the 1950s it really
much was a case of um
virtue virtue ethics let's say being
applied by the researcher by the
physician scientists by the
um
aristocrat who had a hobby on the side
of conducting research and an
expectation that they ought to conduct
themselves in a virtuous manner
but there wasn't necessarily a kind of
committee at play or a body or a group
of individuals who would assess prior to
any research experimentation
observational
taking place
to give it some sort of ethical green
license ethical approbation
so what we see primarily through the
great work of laura stark and historian
at vanderbilt university
uh through her her fantastic book on
irbs in the united states
um the modern form of the ethics
committee the irb can be traced to the
1950s and in particular the nih clinical
center
for the for the this new type of
research participant who came into being
namely the healthy human volunteer the
non-patient
an individual who would
willingly knowingly give themselves to
science and say i'm happy to participate
in this trial this this experiment
subject of course to knowing the risks
and expected benefits and anything else
that is material for me to make a
competent decision
and so you had this sort of genesis in
1950s 1960s that started in the us and
really was put on firm and firmer
footing with a a us surgeon general memo
to all recipients of grounds from the
u.s public health service that more or
less said
if you want to be recipient of a public
health service ground
which which includes the nih and
there needs to be a prior review
of the judgments of the principal
investigator in terms of the right
welfare of the individual of the
appropriateness of the methods used to
secure informed consent and of the risks
and potential medical benefits of the
investigation there's a few things to
note here
one already informed consent plain
essential role
risks and expected benefits but notice
also the biomedical focus here and so
it's really important to emphasize as as
many of you might know anyway
the modern ethics committee and the
genesis of ethics review really started
from biomedicine but of course we know
that it's expanded over the decades to
go well beyond just the biomedical
domain
so it's important to then ask
knowing that the irb the ethics
committee the wreck has been an
existence wreck meaning research ethics
committee that's the term we use in the
uk
um for
70 plus years or about 70 years now
what do they do
well there's different ways that we can
we can investigate that question we can
we can survey ethics committee and
members we can survey research
applicants who submit their applications
and protocols to an ethics committee um
we can we can we can interview um tinker
and coomer did a survey of uk university
ethics committees um
back in the early 2000s
and i it's still the most comprehensive
report we have of university ethics
meetings in the uk
but i very much think this is
generalizable across
other forms of ethics communities it
certainly accord with what i saw in my
empirical research of of nhs for certain
ethics in these national health service
ethics committees which we'll speak
about in a second and i would venture to
say very similar to what happens at
university and institutional and review
boards in the united states and in other
jurisdictions
perhaps number three is the basic
element that we would associate most
prominently
ethical scrutiny of research
applications the primary uh objective
and object of an ethics committee is to
receive
an application with all the relevant
attended documents the protocol perhaps
the information sheet and consent form
other things nowadays including
potentially a data management plan
depending on we'll speak about that in a
second
to assess
the the ethical issues that are
identified either by the applicant uh
and or also by the equity members and to
determine whether or not it's ethically
acceptable in other words can it receive
approval from that moment of assessment
or does it need to be further inquiry in
terms of questions put back to the
applicant
or concern
that means that it needs to be
rejected and then resubmitted
but there's a role that goes beyond
ethical scrutiny of applications alone
ethics committees also have a
responsibility
for for ethical issues in a broader
sense including maintaining standards
and provision of advice to researchers
not something i'll touch on in a minute
very much i would i would suggest and
indeed argue
ethics committee members also are there
to provide advice and not simply to
police or see or or
or gatekeep research from taking place
they are ultimately many of many of them
researchers themselves pastor currently
who are there to support researchers
and ultimately to guide their research
project through the life cycle not just
there as they say to police and gatekeep
and to say yes no so the provision of
ice of advice is a crucial role we ought
to keep in mind too
reporting and monitoring is a more
interesting one there it depends on the
jurisdiction some and and and guidelines
or standard operating procedures
and otherwise some ethics committees are
required to have an annual review that
they that they want researchers once
their projects have been approved to
send to them
how has your research gone over the past
12 months have you come across any new
ethical issues how are you
addressing any ethical issues that are
identified both in the original
application or new ones that have come
come into place once your project has
gotten off the ground
but generally ethics committees
are there in what we might call the
ex-ante stage before things begin
they receive the application
before the project is meant to begin and
that's that's understandable in the
sense that the only way to protect
participants are arguably the only way
or the best way to protect participants
against the risk of harm from
materializing physical harm or as we'll
talk about the second informational harm
it has to be done before the research
itself commences before personal data is
processed before things actually start
to come into beam
but that doesn't mean that don't they
don't have or shouldn't have a role to
play once the project has gotten off the
ground
but it is to say that reporting and
monitoring i think it's fair to say is
limited limited because of resources and
other reasons
and then lastly the responsibility for
ensuring production and maintenance of
code to practice and guidance is very
much dependent on the terms of reference
of any given ethics committee
and where they sit in an institution or
or other body so if they are for example
and in the uk context universities often
have
research ethics within a college or at
the highest level across the university
and then there's those that are situated
within departments or faculties or
schools
generally the school and departmental
ethics committees do not
write codes of practice guidance but the
higher level ones do
and very much will depend on the
particular ethics committee but some
will have a responsibility for producing
codes of practice and guidance
when it comes to the role of an ethics
city given that that's what they are
seeing to do we might ask
so what's their what's their primary
objective beyond sort of assessing the
ethical acceptability of an ethics
application
well this is taken from the health
research authority's governance
framework for research ethics committees
gaffer
as as it's known uh a tongue twister
vernacular
and i should say that the health
research authority as the name implies
regulates health research in the uk
albeit very much big data driven machine
machine learning driven health research
but still in the context of health
and they have a responsibility for
ethics committees that are within the
nhs the national health service the
health the health service that exists in
the uk remember in the uk health health
care is free
or taxpayer funded i should say and but
it's free at the point of of use and and
that means that there's a treasure trove
of data because everyone in the uk is an
nhs patient and across the four nations
of the uk so you're talking about
65 to 70 million at
individual data subjects so a tremendous
troll of data so a lot of researchers um
often make applications to these ethics
committees to
use the patient's data that might be
identifiable data
or or partially anonymized or fully
anonymized
and so these efficiencies play a
valuable role it's worth noting that
there are two roles that and
the governance framework for research
and ethics committees identifies and the
question is are they are they situated
on the same plane or is there a primary
role in the secondary role well it seems
that there is indeed a sort of primary
role but a really important secondary
role the primary role perhaps not
surprisingly
is the protection of the interests of
research participants
so
this document speaks to their dignities
rights safety and well-being and that
has to be the primary consideration in
any proposal as well as in the ethics
committee reviewed by that research
attitude the wreck
and of course they talk about proportion
of safeguards which is important and
something we'll speak about in a minute
but there's also the secondary role
which is acting primarily in the
interests of research participants
and
and that has to be secondary to the
dignity uh rights is the safety and
well-being of people taking part in
research so that's that's the primary
that's primary the interests of
researchers in research must be
secondary
to the protection of the rights and
welfare of participants themselves
so what you see here is there is an
interest in value and a role for ethics
committees to be mindful of science and
society but it must necessarily be
secondary to the protection of research
participants so that's a really
important point that we'll come back to
so
we can think then there might be this
principal aim in the second area and the
principal name being protection the
welfare of perspective and current
participants as well as this secondary
promotion of ethical and socially
valuable research and think about that
comment earlier about ethics committees
are also there to provide advice and and
perhaps to go beyond just that
ex-anti-stage of policing
and approving yes no an ethics
application but working with researchers
to provide
support and guidance throughout the life
cycle of research and therefore that
secondary aim becomes really important
so this this notion
uh of the evaluation of ethics issues of
a proposed project by committee of
people and ethics committee and irb
qualified in some way so
it will depend on the particular
committee in terms of reference are
there certain experts that need to sit
on the committee how many must be
experts in the field are there any lay
participants and so on and so forth but
there is a body of people committed
people 12 to 18 somewhere between the
numbers to assess a project's ethics
issues we might say arguably
that's that's necessary but not
necessarily sufficient
for the successful functioning of them
securing public trust in research
it's not enough i would argue that if we
want to sustain public trust in any
research whether it's ai
and big data driven as we get through in
a second or otherwise
that we say oh it's been ethically
approved nair b has approved it it's we
have to go beyond that it's it's
necessary but perhaps not sufficient so
it is simply a pragmatic system of
social control
by by researchers academic and community
peers that's what irbs and ethics
communities do they it's a social
control of science and that and that's a
recognition it's a pragmatic system very
much an american philosophy that's why
they started i would argue the nih
clinical center is a
an ingenious proposal but it's very
pragmatic proposal too to have a
committee of of reviewers so we say
but
again where we're going in science given
where we're going to research it can be
queried whether this pragmatic system of
social control remains fit for purpose
in the 21st century particularly in
light of internationally collaborative
data intensive science and emerging
technology practices
and so let's now focus then on the area
of ai data science and big data and
think about some of these themes that
throw up challenges or research ethics
governance in particular the board of
ethics committees
so
i don't need to tell you
that all of the advances in
computational analytical techniques
analytic techniques and digital
technologies have led to a tremendous
increase the amount of digital data
produced and available to be processed
that's what we talked about we say big
data you know it's all obviously the 3ds
potentially 5vs potentially 7bs there's
a variety of these to talk about
volume for the variety of velocity etc
etc but that's what we're talking about
tremendous advances in computational
analytic techniques and digital
technologies massive increase in data
and that means then that research
projects increasingly are processing a
variety of data through a variety of
means
this really is data hoovering on a large
scale and the ethos of course big data
is generally speaking the more the
better the more data we can collect the
better maybe we can find the signal in
this a tremendous amount of noise that
we're generating but there's several
themes there that are merged here
one we can talk about a shift from human
subjects the lingo the parlance that we
talked about from the 20th century tumor
21st century and this obviously comes
from data protection along europe the
notion of a data subject
and that's the legal term of course in
data protection law but i think that's
perhaps what we're going through this is
less about the human per se
in a sort of corporeal sense and much
more about who they are in terms of
their data points so we are i think
shifting from a human subject to a data
subject that also then means when we
think about research involving human
participants or research involving human
subjects of research relating to human
subjects we shift from direct
involvement
more towards indirect involvement and
what does that mean
well partly when we think about the
notion of risk given that that's a
primary
form of assessment and in the governance
model of that expedia is a sort of risk
assessment and calibration of
standards proportionate to the level of
risk of project rates
the risk also just from physical or
psychological harm towards risk of
informational harm and that's what we
mean we remove the data subjects and
indirect involvement of research
participants involving various data
points
dignitarian arms as well as
informational harms
and so i don't need to go into detail
about the various methods that apply in
in ai dat and in data intensive research
all of those i assume are you're well
familiar with as well as the various
categories of data and the sources of
data
from which these various data can be
collected the network can be open and
closed crowdsource can come from a
variety of uh public and semi-public or
private databases as well
so what does that mean then well let's
let's apply that those sort of themes
back to ethics committees and we'll
start with some of the classic
criticisms that have arisen with ethics
committees and think about how some of
the new ones are also being raised and
what this means then for the fitness for
purpose test that we'll talk about
well one we can't avoid
the fact that ethic committees have
grown just as we're talking about growth
in data there is a growth of the ethics
committee as well
so research itself has grown the amount
of research being conducted uh the the
international collaborative nature of
research
the duration of research the funding
involved in research
and necessarily then we have to talk
about a growth of the regulation of
research
and of course
very few would argue that we should
operate in a world of zero regulation
just as we should operate in a world of
economic trade and various sorts of
human activities in a form of regulation
thinking about again
the definition of regulation steering
of human behavior in a socially or
economically and politically desirable
manner how totally what regulation is
and so just with research and its growth
there has been a concavity rise of its
regulation
and i've already made the argument that
regulation i think includes assessment
of ethical acceptability
and we might indeed call
irbs and
institutional review boards or research
activities research ethics regulatory
communities or institutional regulatory
committees but i don't think we'll shift
in that parlance at any time soon
and but i think that's an accurate
reflection of what in fact they do
[Music]
do it's also important in speaking about
the growth of the ethics committee the
hybridity of ethics committee systems in
many countries so
the u.s is in to my knowledge an
entirely um institutional based system
but that's actually not the norm many
countries operate a sort of hybrid
system like in the uk for example where
we have institution based ethics
committees primarily at higher education
institutions so colleges and
universities as well as our region-based
ethics committee so the nhs research
ethics committees that are situated in
the four nations of the uk but still
technically representing a region of
scotland england wales or northern
ireland
ethics committees do
retain a gatekeeping function i think
that is fair to say they do
ultimately play a role and they might
arguably have to play a role under a law
depending on the jurisdiction depending
on the type of research if it's a
clinical trial that is a law that they
have
to to review and assess and approve a
clinical trial before it can take place
but there's all sorts of research
projects including your um
you know your master's level or phd
level project that involves perhaps uh
personal data uh um or some sort of
involvement of human participants that
through policy or some form of
regulation also will require to people
and therefore they do keep they
determine whether or not your research
as presented to them can go forward
but there has been a shift
from this 1950s nih clinical center ad
hoc physician peer reviewer to a
quasi-professionalized
institutionalized diverse body of
experts what i mean by that there's not
a professional body of irb members of
rec members per se but there are
organizations like primr in the us and
other organizations and other countries
that seek to professionalize which is
not a bad thing the work of irb members
and administrators but that has created
its own sort of um
[Music]
various questions
and ways of working rituals and
otherwise and that means that there has
been a growth of rules of standards um
and in turn uh reflections on on how
researchers go about doing their work
including
the preparation of an application for
ethics review
and so what we have then is a much more
institutionalized and embedded
regulatory event licensing system
through ethics communities they provide
the event license to the applicant you
can you can proceed to conduct your
research or not
so
this of course this growth of ethics
committee in the work that they do has
led to long-standing criticisms not
necessarily tied to
ai and data intensive science
so
the the primary criticism is very much
one of bureaucracy mission creep red
tape and a concern that we are now
living in a tick box tick box form of
ethics
not one of the classic you know
pre-pre-world of uh pre-irb world of a
virtue ethicist driven type of research
where the individual researcher was
expected through various sorts of social
norms and otherwise to conduct
themselves in a virtuous manner without
the need for this regulatory approval by
an ethics committee
so
in the uk in european context i can tell
you when the eu clinical trials directly
2001 came into effect and that was 2003
it was domesticated in the member states
laws many countries thought this was the
end of self-regulation of research
ethics and there's now these these legal
standards that we need to abide by when
it comes to ethics committee review not
just the clinical trials but ultimately
it came out to be all form of research
in this case involving nhs patients
which as i say and is a lot of health
research in the uk given the nature of
our health care system and there was a
real lament
of
the 21st century leading to an
increasing amount of bureaucracy in
terms of the ethics application form
increasing in length he attended
documents that needed to be drafted
to ultimately secure these approvals
not just ethics approvals of course but
by clinical trial approvals from the
drugs regulator and otherwise so
this lament is really being sustained by
the research community and an article i
think this is from the british medical
journal in 2008 and a biomedical
researcher made the case that in a risk
benefit arena that is now heavily
stacked towards perceived risk
the instigators of over-regulation must
bear responsibility for the real and
emerging risks of failure to deliver the
potential life-saving benefits of
clinical research properly in other
words
the risk-benefit ratio is no longer
calibrated appropriately and risk is now
heavily stocked towards
an over assessment of all forms of risk
and and and those who are responsible
they need to think about what research
is being thwarted what research is being
prevented from taking place including
life-saving research because of this
over-regulation bureaucracy and that
tape
now some of these
criticisms as they stress are hardly new
so you know
i i remember reading an article from
dale cowan who was a us irb chair about
1974.
already in 1974 so this is only only you
know less than a decade after the us
surgeon general's memo
of his concern about the sheer weight of
the bureaucracy which has been proposed
to regulate human experimentation
many investigators and review committees
are already of the opinion that the
paperwork involved preparing approving
acceptance protocols is extensive and
taxing
and in the textbook that i edit mason
mccall smith's law on medical ethics we
have a quote in our previous edition
that said one of the ironies
in this area is that there may now be so
many instruments regulations and guides
that the system itself is standing in
the way of good ethical research
so that's been the sustained criticism
over decades this concern of bureaucracy
and paperwork and
increasing amounts of paperwork that's
extensive and taxing both for ethics
committee members but certainly also for
research applicants
and yet
more recent criticisms particularly in
light of ai and
science have come from the opposite
direction
namely that it's too much bureaucracy or
sorry rather than it being too much
bureaucracy it's about under coverage
in particular ai and data intensive
research so it's it's about gaps and
loopholes in research ethics governance
rather than mission-free bureaucracy uh
and red tape which is quite interesting
to think about how they come from very
opposite ends
so let's look in particular some of
these challenges
one arguably is a scope challenge
thinking about these gaps in loopholes
in other words is ai and data science
research within the purview of ethics
review well i mentioned already
how
the paradigm of ethics
committee work and research i think
government very much has come from
biomedicine and we see that from the
declaration of helsinki we see it from
the nuremberg code and we see it uh from
from really from the common rule as well
indeed from much of the belmont report
quite famous in the u.s which did give
credence to social science research but
very much on past songs shall we say
so there really has been a bio medical
ethics framework application
potentially to ai and data science as
well but that means is it appropriate to
take those concepts and principles from
biomedicine individual autonomy and
individual participant risks and
expected benefits as distinct from
something that might be more appropriate
in ai and data science research and i'm
speaking about societal risks and
expected benefits group harms including
group privacy harms and informational
dimensions
another question about scope is many
countries permit research projects to
forego ethics review or have it subject
to proportion review if anonymized data
are used i believe that's the case in
the us i will stand corrected if i'm
wrong that's also the case for example
in the uk and switzerland
and but i think it's fair to say also
that it is increasingly difficult to
ensure that data actually fulfill
whatever criteria is necessary in in the
uk and european products as a legal
criteria under
general data protection regulation and
domesticated data protection acts to
establish that data are indeed
anonymized in other words fully and
irreversibly de-identified rather than
personal or pseudonymized or let's use
the term key coded
in other words can they
adequately and legally forego ethics
review because they in fact do not
constitute personal data i think that's
an increasingly difficult uh dimension
and and difficult criterion to fulfill
and of course the risk of identifying
individuals from the data is often very
difficult to determine quantifiably or
otherwise
and then there's another question is
ethics committee review required for
research on pre-existing data sets
that's of course a tremendous aspect of
data science research it's not about the
generation of new data sets it's
research performed i've already
collected data
and of course the question is can one or
should one rely on the underlying
consent or permission
from those data subjects if there even
is a content and that's often not the
case
and then there's another dimension about
scope which is privately funded studies
may not be subject to the same research
protections and ethical regulations as
publicly funded research you think about
public-private partnerships liaisons
between universities and industry and
otherwise and what does that mean for
obligations to undergo ethics review or
not and if so who takes responsibility
or is it the case that you have
duplicative multiple ethics reviews
which of course raises a number of
challenges and issues in its own right
i think there's a second challenge which
is about assessing and operationalizing
these research participant consents in
other words thinking about this
principle of no surprises for data
subjects is the research activity or
data processing activity you're going to
be doing would that would that come as a
surprise to them
and would it be in accordance with their
reasonable expectations of data use and
if the answer to either question is that
no i'm not sure i think that that
requires deep ethical reflection
but this is particularly because as i
say when it comes to secondary use quite
often consent might not be at play in
that given data set and we know in
particular from social media
which are very often used for research
purposes without participants explicit
consent or awareness and that's just
that just goes without saying use of
data collected from tick tock twitter
facebook and otherwise is not done with
the explicit consent awareness of any
given user of that of that social media
platform
and i think we ought to very clearly
distinguish more than we do
consent provided from a research ethic
standpoint versus what we call talk
about in european data protection law
consent as a legal basis to process
personal data and we need to not
conflate those two concepts lest we
confuse
everyone including participants ethics
members and researchers
and how both of those concepts fit in
within recent expectations of privacy
so consent
remains a very open question and of
course we also must not treat consent as
a panacea for all ethical concerns it
shouldn't be the case that we can say
well we need a new consent or let's rely
on this old consent and because there is
a consent we can squeeze in
all the information we need to in other
words this kind of um
how can i say it almost a sort of um
liberal approach liberal in the sense of
assuming there's a rational individual
and if we provide all material
information consent form they've read it
they've signed it they know what they're
signing up to buyer beware i think we
have to be careful about treating
consensus of panacea for all ethical
concerns and not thinking about larger
sort of governance frameworks and and
and social norms and ethical norms we
ought to still abide by even if consent
is there
and then finally there's this challenge
of disharmonization and inadequate
expertise in data science
methods and data ethics so
there's two elements here of course we
know there's inconsistency across and
within ethics committees including
within the same university or our region
and so the uk for example has not
resolved the issue of multi-site
multi-university research much less as
they say when there's collaboration with
commercial um
in industry when it comes to data-driven
research so this lack of standardization
and consistency is a tremendous
challenge from so many countries this
harmonization is a real concern
particularly when we speak about
internationally collaborative research
and another concern of course is the
challenge of an expertise a number of
irb
members and research facility members
i've adventure to say are not experts in
data ethics data protection law or i.t
security
and therefore they may well feel outside
their comfort zone when it comes to
reviewing an ai or data science project
and what what are
what what rules or principles or
guidances in place for any given editing
to deal with that what happens i suspect
many are silent and it's just just to
rely on the expertise of any given irb
or wreck and you say well you know you
can apply the general principles of
knowledge you gain from your years as a
member but
we we i think can query whether that's
appropriate in this world of data
intensive science
so
these i think are also two really
important challenges are two
sub-challenges in this challenge three
of disharmonization and inadequate
expertise
so the question then becomes
know these are serious challenges or
ethics media is actually purpose still
in the 21st century well
i i want to make the case that yes i
think broadly speaking and to make it a
short answer also keeping keeping
mindful of time i think ethics
committees do remain fit for purpose
broadly speaking their regulatory design
is not perfect nor is implementation
but much like we speak about democracy
being the least bad of all other
possible forms of government we might
say that ethics committees are the least
bad of all other possible structures to
serve as a social control of science
and to facilitate and promote those two
names of participant protection and
ethical research promotion thinking
again about the advice giving nature
that efforts means can or should instill
and inculcate
but that doesn't mean that in light of
these these
developing areas of science in
particular ai and machine human
interactions and democratization of
science i think about citizen science
some modifications to
research ethics design or scientific
governance design and performance and is
not warranted it is i think
so i'll speak very briefly about some of
the themes that emerged in the book that
jack mentioned already regulatory
stewardship of health research
this was an empirical project that
brought me to england and scotland over
more than a year
sitting in in various nhs research
ethics meetings and speaking with
members and regulators and
conducting interviews uh documentary
analysis and and of course field notes
with my with my sort of ethnographic
type research and ultimately um
you know what i observed was a lot of
ethics companies don't don't know what
other ethics days are doing you know
there are these sort of networking
events that happen once or twice a year
but generally they operate in a black
box in the case of nhs research
opportunities there was surprising and
tremendous group homogeneity in approach
rituals so one could be in various
ethics meetings in different parts of
the country but they would still operate
surprisingly similarly in terms of how
they conduct themselves the issues they
discussed but i can tell you now having
in the midst of conducting research
that's still ongoing with the university
ethics committees in the uk very
different much more buried in approach
and venture to say institutional review
boards institutional committees
generally operate very differently
but there is a strong emphasis to
preserve the sanctity of their black box
and their ethics of space even if they
don't know what others are doing they
don't want to change
regulatory connectivity was another
major theme so law and science occupy
these uncertain relationships with epic
means
they know they're not supposed to review
the methodology the scientific methods
that should already be done by the
funder or someone else but they often do
review science and the methods and i
don't think that's necessarily a bad
thing we know there's an intertwining of
science and ethics and indeed law i
think increasingly plays an important
role and we know it will through
information governance and data
protection and privacy given the nature
of research in the 21st century and i
think ethics committees can operate as
stewards helping researchers navigate
these various spaces of science and law
more than they're given credit for
and so that third theme regulators of
stewards did really come through uh in
my research that they really
can encourage researchers and support
them not simply be seen as police police
persons and watchdogs
gatekeeping and saying yes no only at
the initial stage but really trying to
work with researchers throughout the
life cycle of their project to help them
make their research as successful and
ethically valid
as as possible and socially valuable as
possible
so there is there are opportunities for
development and i'll just end i think um
not so much on these notions that came
through uh in in my work and if you're
interested in reading about and
learning about regulatory flexibility
and conversations and stewardship
by all means you can have a look it is
open access so it's available on
everyone at no cost uh through through
edward algar so if you just pull
but let me focus more about sort of the
the this domain
i'm thinking about ai and data intensive
science
obviously resources for sources
resources are crucial here there needs
to be systemic support within
institutions within government
and
to provide greater funding and yes
professionalization possibly paid
training guidance
and we'll talk about sort of ad-hoc
committees and pools of experts and
citizens in a moment but there has to be
much greater emphasis given to a system
of accreditation
qualifications and certification of
ethics committees
standard operating procedures to ensure
procedural consistency i think there's
real value in templates often and
templates are there of course for
inspiration they're not meant to be uh
carbon copied onto any given application
but they are tremendously invaluable
particularly when we're thinking about
ai and data intensive science and we
need to think about how we draw forms
for these forms of research different
from the biomedical domain and the
questions and things that need to be
thought about are very different
so i think template review forms and
information sheets and consent forms
would be tremendously valuable for the
research community
and i'll also very briefly just the
interest of time give credence to uh a a
project that i worked on with agatha
ferretti and effie bienna and their team
um
at uh zurich in switzerland and we had a
nice discussion um in the midst of the
pandemic about a year and a half ago
thinking about ethics review big day
urge what should stay and what should be
reformed and we came up with sort of
three sort of categories of reforms so
again not throwing the baby out with the
bath water we still think ethics
communities have a role to play
but they ought to indeed have reform
some more radical than others but
generally not radically informed but but
important reform
guidance would be really
valuable for research and research
committees for certifications as well as
researchers on the ethics issues within
ai and data science research and in turn
help think about that scope question is
my research
should should or must my research be
submitted to an ethics committee at all
and if so what do i need in this in the
in the course of submitting that
protocol that application for review
we can think about procedural reforms so
new ethical assessment tools that would
be valuable to fx committees
external consultation those who are
skilled in data science and data ethics
and data protection and i.t security
ethics committee members ultimately i
think
should have training in ai and data
science research so they don't feel
uncomfortable when they receive an
application from this domain
and and so that might that might lead to
tweaks to terms of reference as well as
i said
governance frameworks for ethics
committees themselves and ultimately
i think there's always scope for more
engagement with researchers and data
subjects more stakeholder engagement is
absolutely valuable here
there might be a role for a new
specialized committee that sits
alongside an ethics committee maybe a
kind of data ethics cd or data ethics
review board but of course that will
lead to concerns about duplication and
confusion and so i'm not sure a
specialized committee is the answer or
where we need to go just yet
so i think ultimately then
it's not about sort of a no more wreck i
think we ought to think about it though
um going beyond as i say this ex
anti-regulatory licensing to um you know
a more embedding of ethics across a life
cycle it's not about going to expose
review and audit so let all research
projects
start without any ethics review and
we'll just sort of audit one out of
every 10 that have taken place and see
if anything went wrong i don't think
that's the right answer i think either
committee should play a role at the
ex-ante stage
to say think about how it's embedded
across a life cycle and i think that's
ultimately what this idea and concept of
regulatory stewardship is all about
that's really what i sort of emphasized
in my book so
i i leave it for about five minutes for
questions i very very much thank you for
your time and i'm happy to to answer any
questions so that's a a picture of old
college the law school at the university
of edinburgh uh on a typical scottish
weather day not blue skies and but but
not too bad never really much snow and i
want to thank my current funder the
carnegie trust for the universities of
scotland who's uh funding me for my my
ongoing research on university ethics
committees in scotland across the
scottish universities so thank you very
much
thank you ted that was fantastic such a
great overview of things i think it you
know transcends as we sort of discussed
a little bit earlier transcends kind of
international boundaries with a lot of
these uh irb and and regulatory aspects
to how we do science especially now that
as you kind of pointed out things are so
data rich now and
one of the things i wanted to ask you is
do you feel that um institutional review
boards and those regulatory agencies uh
you know you sort of touched on this do
you feel that they are getting adequate
training and they understand what kind
of the data sets are how big they are
what kind of you know there's always
information about you know uh
say uh uh personal identific personal
identifiers but do you think they get a
sense of like what the goals of
large-scale data science are are about
that's a great question jack i mean
yeah
the the the short answer is no i don't
think they are um
and it depends of course on the
jurisdiction so i can speak first of my
of my research involving nhs research
ethics committees there because those
ethics committees are um
funded if you will by by the nhs in each
of the four nations and so in other
words the sort of state-run ethics
committees
generally there's a a much more
consistent and standard approach for
induction of members both when they join
as well as ongoing sort of annual
training
and there they often run workshops on
sort of new and emerging areas of
research
in of course the context of of health
research in particular clinical research
and biomedical research
um but i know that ethics means within
those
86 i think committees there are and
nhs rex there are across the uk
i would venture to say there they are
relatively well trained and kept up to
speed
on new and
emerging methodologies including data
tensor science and big data type
research including for example
all of the tremendous cobia 19 research
that the uk has led on genomic
sequencing and otherwise in these huge
data sets of nhs patients which have led
to already tremendous breakthroughs in
terms of of of treatments that that work
for coca-19 patients
and from institutional ethics committees
your irbs or you know as what i'm
discovering universities in scotland
it's much more of a grab bag some
universities provide training only when
new members join
some provide a
none at all and very few if any provide
ongoing training including sort of
workshops for
members on various things and if they do
it's sort of a voluntary thing if if
you're able
to join when it works for your schedule
but i fear that that means that many
ethics committee members um
are fumbling in the dark with these with
these sorts of of of data intensive
methods and the various
ethics issues that are particularly
related to ai
um and related forms of research
and and technologies and therefore i
think that it it doesn't really help
participants it doesn't help researchers
and it doesn't help the ethics committee
or the institution so i think a lot more
can be done but as i say that's really a
question of resource and the question is
is there the will to invest more in the
resources to provide that training for
effective communities so that ultimately
participants are protected data subjects
are protected the institution is
protected and you're ultimately creating
better science as a result
there's another organization i think the
acronym is
c-i-o-m-s i'm not really familiar with
it but apparently they have uh some
ethical principles for epidemiological
research and it seems that these may be
maybe a little more informed about big
data science than say the original
declaration of helsinki or the belmont
report or things that are derivative
thereof can you say a few words about
what uh the c c what is it
yeah diamonds okay
yeah and it's something like the count
international council of medical
sciences or something camera exactly the
acronym stands for but they um
they they put out uh they put out since
1982 sort of the international uh
guidelines for research involving
participants originally the remit was
much more for research conducted in
developing countries the concern was
the declaration of seeking others was
for researchers conducting research in
their own jurisdictions and there was a
concern that researchers were going to
other parts of the world that were that
were um
had less regulations and laws in place
to protect participants and there was
concern of unethical research being
conducted primarily clinical trials and
and so that was original sort of genesis
of the 1982 guidelines
the more recent ones 2016
are seen as sort of the gold standard
for all forms of of research involved
between participants not even within the
biomedical context so including
epidemiological type research generally
scions is a is a fantastic organization
that puts out frameworks guidelines
codes for researchers and all different
domains not only medical science but
that's still the primary one that they
focus on
including for emerging technologies and
and
and methods
and techniques in data intensive science
so an organization like science would be
great in the sense that it's guidance
that in principle should be available to
all committees and all all participants
all researchers internationally the
question is you know how much is it
actually focused on the particular type
of research that that
researcher is conducting and how
relevant is it to that particular
jurisdiction in terms of their laws and
frameworks otherwise but science is a
great example of organization that is
trying to make headway in this area
are there any other
resources or organizations or any
scholars that are also writing about
this shift from kind of human subject
focused data to kind of like big data as
the research subject itself is there
there's some folks who want to read more
about it oh that's a great question jack
um
so i mean um
i'm trying i don't mean to put you on
the spot ted if you know
if you were to though to maybe send us a
list of those we could make it available
to our participants i think that would
be wonderful i would be happy to be
happy to provide a sort of a reading
list and viewing this for those that
might be interested in sort of um
data ethics research ethics issues
related to ai type research and you know
thinking in particular about um you know
because i just read the second edition
of his book rob kitchen who's based at
minute university in ireland uh those
who are focused on critical data studies
so thinking critically about big data
including implications for society
promoting big data research but doing so
in a way that is thought through the
societal implications and ethical
implications not to mention of course
equilibrication so i think rob kitchen's
second edition of his book um came with
the title top of my head but that it's
really a magnum opus in the field so um
but i'd be happy to put together a
little short reading and viewing this
for everyone that'd be wonderful well
ted thank you so much for sharing this
uh great discussion with us and and your
work in this area this is so important
to the future of
big data science to you know how we're
doing things with new ai developments
and and their applications in in
understanding health and disease uh
worldwide so thank you so much for
sharing the perspective from edinburgh
we really appreciate it um thank you
everybody who joined us and uh everyone
have a wonderful weekend and uh we'll
see you next week thanks again ted thank
you thank you